here now senator josh hawley of missouri
i just think
hillary clinton doesn't even know what
she's doing she points to vanity fair
to show how to cover something they
covered up the epstein deal
senator hawley do you think she's even
aware of that
you know what i think is really
happening here jesse is it's clear now
there was collusion after all in the
2016 campaign and the collusion was
between hillary clinton and some tech
executives who did in fact spy on donald
trump who did access his email servers
and worse than that
who went on according to special counsel
went on to try and infiltrate that is
spyon the executive office of the
president of the united states i mean
this is this is some crazy crazy stuff
that hillary has been involved in and
now it turns out the clinton campaign
was really just a criminal enterprise
which is what we've known all along
somebody should go to jail for this and
i hope the special counsel is pretty
soon going to be talking to hillary
clinton can you do anything about this
you must have some sort of subpoena
power i mean you're a powerful senator
you're on a bunch of really important
committees senator there must be
something you could do at least kick up
some dust with these corrupt people
well you know i think that i just
discovered a good use for that january 6
committee over there in the house i mean
once republicans take back the house
this november if that committee really
wants to look into interference in
presidential elections why don't they
start there the 2016 presidential
election that hillary clinton tried to
steal by colluding with big tech by
spying on her opponent and yes by lying
to the fbi and then lying to federal
courts that looks like something that's
worthy of investigation to me all right
well they want to investigate you for a
mug
that you're selling on a website
i don't know what the big deal is you
have a mug people can buy it on your
website this is a big scandal in dc
would you like to issue a statement
senator
oh absolutely i mean it's such an
outrage they say that i am fearlessly
and unrepentantly representing my state
you know people said jesse they they
said that i would uh that i was
supporting a riot back on january 6 that
they said that that i was a stirring up
insurrection all lies what i've have
been doing and will continue to do is to
represent the views of the people of my
state to stand up for election integrity
to stand up for fair elections and if
you want to buy the mug go to josh
hawley.com all right okay so you can't
do this you can't put the fist up in
there you can do hands up don't shoot
but you how dare you do the fist just
wrong thank you senator hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else